are these supplements the gate cut
secrets to permanent weight loss
honestly this is one of those videos I
never thought I was gonna make
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we'll be discussing the weight
loss supplement World The Good the Bad
and the super sketch a super quick thank
you to my dietitian colleague Erin Davis
for research assistance on this video
Aaron is amazing she specializes in
insulin resistance from a weight neutral
lens so I will be leaving a link below
to our website if you're looking for
some one-on-one Support also a reminder
to hit up my description for my full
disclaimer and Trigger warning we will
be talking about weight loss and numbers
I also want to make it super duper clear
here that I am not advocating for the
use of any of these supplements I've
been asked about weight loss supplements
Ad nauseam and ultimately my job as a
science Communicator is to put my own
bias aside and to communicate the
evidence as best as I can to help you
make the most informed decisions in the
sea of misinformation and you can also
find a link to my Hunger crushing combo
ebook for free and my ltk page for this
week's looks first I want to talk about
today's sponsor June's Journey so
everyone who knows me knows that I love
a good murder mystery and a few months
ago I discovered June's Journey as an
alternative to just washing True Crime
docs on Netflix and it has been a really
really great way to unwind much better
than Dateline that's for sure but this
is a really cool Hidden Object mystery
game set in the 1920s available for free
on Android and Apple mobile devices and
on desktop through Amazon or Facebook I
heard about it through someone on my
team and apparently it has a huge huge
following like more than 30 million
people are playing this thing worldwide
I used to never play online games but it
has become a really nice distraction
after a really busy day that actually
requires some brain and critical
thinking skills this has got a solid
storyline based around the protagonist
June who is on a quest to solve the
murder of her sister and uncover her
family's Secrets the beautiful colorful
Graphics are set in the Glamorous 1920s
and you get the chance to customize
Remodel and fix your mansion and Garden
Island I am really admittedly into
design especially when I don't have to
pay for it so this has definitely become
my favorite part of the game so if you
want to try out June's Journey yourself
click the link in my description or use
the QR code on screen to download the
game on Android and iOS mobile devices
or through Facebook games on your PC
okay so the world is clearly on an
exemptic kick with loads of laypeople
online trying to mimic its
groundbreaking results with diet and
over-the-counter supplements this new
weight loss drug could be more effective
than ozembic yeah so let's talk about
L-Carnitine and why I use it to help me
with my fat loss so the five weight loss
supplements that actually work if you
want to shred and burn fat you need to
get on my favorite supplement the fat
burning supplement world is definitely
not new we've had Decades of huge
promises from the Natural Health
Community alongside a few major
controversies and some tragic fatalities
along the way so let's take a look at
the best evidence that we have to date
and at the end we will see which of
these supplements are actually worth the
hype first up I want to talk about
berberine so berberine's kind of like
the hottest supplement of 2023 and I've
got a whole video discussing all of the
evidence on this so-called Nature's
ozempic but as a quick recap berberine
works like weight loss drugs in a few
key ways so it produces intestinal glp-1
it may help to optimize the gut
microbiome for carbohydrate metabolism
and it may inhibit the enzyme that
determines how much sugar your body
absorbs the result is that it helps
people lose weight
how much weight let's talk about it Risa
suggests that after three months of
berberine supplementation participants
lost about three percent of their body
weight is this significant I mean it
definitely could be for some people but
if you're 150 pounds that means just 4.5
pound loss in three months or less than
0.4 pounds per week I don't want to poo
poo on anybody's party but not exactly
something that I would write home about
or compare with a powerful
pharmaceutical like ozempic especially
considering that the clinical dosage is
between 1.5 and 2 grams per day split up
in three to four doses per day that said
I think it has a lot of potential as an
adjunct especially for insulin
resistance I definitely recommend
checking my full video if you want to
know more about that moving on let's
talk about conjugated linoleic acid or
CLA so CLA is naturally found in meat
Dairy and eggs but it's been a popular
supplement in the fitness and weight
loss world for men many years because
it's thought to modulate fat and Insulin
metabolism the research however is less
than conclusive so if we look at one
2019 review it concluded that CLA
supplementation may help to support
weight loss and fat loss so one of the
2019 randomized control trials found
that supplementing with three grams a
day for over three months resulted in
lower body fat Mass body fat percentage
and trunk fat another 2013 trial
basically found the same but other
studies haven't found these significant
perks so for example a 2017 systematic
review of 32 clinical trials concluded
that CLA did not significantly impact
waist circumference or blood sugar
levels it's also really important to
point out that when we say significant
in research lingo we just mean
statistically significant not
necessarily significant to you so if we
look at the actual numbers the 2013
trial found that over 24 weeks the CLA
group lost less than one kilogram more
less than one centimeter off their waist
and less than one BMI Point compared to
the control group oh and you need to
take three grams a day to see any of
those effects is that a win I don't know
that's ultimately up to the individual
to decide but again I think it's clear
that it's not a weight loss pill next
let's talk about capsaicin so capsaicin
is the compound that makes spicy food
spicy and it's also the basis for the
popularity of all these retro diet
crazes like the master cleanse and other
cayenne pepper based detoxes but there
are a number of potential mechanisms for
its use in the weight Lost World for One
it may increase fat oxidation and
inhibit fat cells two it might induce
thermogenesis AKA speed up the
metabolism by activating Brown fat cells
three it may suppress appetite and
crecatidy by regulating neuron circuits
in the hypothalamus and four it may
positively alter the gut microbiome and
the research on spicy food is actually
quite promising one review of the
literature found that kept say some
supplementation helped to improve energy
expenditure thermogenesis fat oxidation
and help to reduce body weight mainly
because of the slight uptick in
metabolism and the reduction in calorie
consumption another meta-analysis of 15
randomized control trials found that
supplementing with capsaicin resulted in
reduced BMI body weight and waist
circumference when compared to the
control group but again how much are we
talking in real life well honestly
it's not that great we're talking less
than a pound difference in a few months
and 0.1 kilograms per meter Square in
BMI
is that going to make a difference to
your health highly unlikely
highly unlikely you'd also likely have
to consume a kind of actual spicy food
to meet the clinical dosage of 100 to
200 milligrams of capsaicin per day now
if you like spicy food then I say sure
there are clear benefits here in the
research but if weight loss is your goal
there's probably not a significant
enough of an impact to justify the cost
of the pills God bless them my brother
I can't do it or to spend all of your
days on the toilet
sitting on toilet next let's talk about
green coffee bean extract you know the
stuff that Dr Oz gotten really bad hot
water for promoting on a show so green
coffee bean extract comes from unroasted
raw coffee beans that contain
antioxidants called chlorogenic acids
which are otherwise destroyed when we
roast coffee otherwise we would get the
same benefits from drinking coffee every
day and while Dr Oz did get in big
trouble for using a completely bogus and
since retracted study that cost the
supplement company who sponsored its
fabrication a whopping 3.5 million
dollars in court there is some
legitimate evidence to support its use
one 2019 review of a total of 13
articles with 16 randomized control
trials found that supplementing with
green coffee bean extract resulted in a
significant reduction in BMI and a
reduction in body weight in those who
are already considered overweight or
obese if we look at a few studies
specifically a recent 2021 randomized
control trial on that folks who
supplemented with chlorogenic acid
isomers aka the active ingredient in
green coffee bean extract had greater
body fat reduction when compared to the
placebo we also have a slightly older
2019 study that found a reduced weight
and waist circumference when compared to
the control but again
how much are we really talking here well
the 2021 study found that it resulted in
0.22 percent loss in body fat and the
waist circumference in the 2019 study
found that it shaved off 0.3 centimeters
off of the participants waist I mean I
could take a big poop and I would lose
more than that so again hardly enough to
make any kind of legitimate difference
in one's health so yeah I think the FTC
was right to crack down on all these
bogus Coffee Bean supplements this is
one that I think we can all agree should
be a big fat pass but while we're
talking about green things let's talk
about green tea extract so like green
coffee beans green tea extracts fat
burning properties comes down to its
antioxidant content green tea is rich in
a catechin antioxidant called egcg which
may help to enhance body fat oxidation
while suppressing hunger hormones so
what does the research say about this
well let's talk about it and gear up
because this one is a bit of a roll
coaster one city found that after 12
weeks of treatment with high dose green
tea extract women with central obesity
experienced significant weight loss
reduced waist circumference lower hunger
hormones and a consistent decrease in
their total cholesterol and LDL plasma
levels without any kind of side effects
or adverse effects another randomized
control trial in overweight participants
found that green tea extract enhanced
the impact of an exercise program by
further reducing weight body mass index
waist to hip ratio and body fat
percentage that said other Studies have
not been so generous one long-term
12-month study found that green tea
extract resulted in no difference in BMI
fat mass or body fat percentage and
another larger view found that any
amount of statistically significant
weight loss found in the literature is
highly unlikely to be clinically
relevant and that's because when we look
at the data it's less than a kilogram
body weight loss or a difference in BMI
of 0.2 kilograms per meter Square not
something worth throwing a party over in
my opinion it's also worth noting that
there have been some serious adverse
side effects associated with weight loss
supplements containing green tea extract
Slim Quick for example has notoriously
been called out for causing liver injury
due specifically to the green tea
extract I really wanted to rank these in
terms of best to worse but honestly
they're all a little dismal if any I
would give berberine the gold prize only
because it has a really good safety
profile but at just three percent weight
loss again it's not a magic pill and
this is really just scratching the
surface when it comes to these alleged
fat burning or weight loss supplements
there are so so so many dubious snake
oil products out there making completely
asinine claims which they can kind of
get away with because the supplement
world is the Wild West it's unregulated
which also means that a lot of them are
subject to overages enriches and in some
cases fatal contamination so so just
because something is natural doesn't
mean that it's benign and even if it is
high quality and safe just because its
claims originate from a shred of decent
research it doesn't mean that it's going
to have any real impact in real life
honestly you'd probably see way better
clinical results and save your money
just by like going to bed an hour
earlier or taking up some kind of
anti-stress routine like meditation
neither of which cause any money and are
100 safe and on that note that's all
that I have for you guys today if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up hit up my description for my
300 question combo ebook subscribe to
the channel and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]